[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
انتم تدرون انه قبل خمسين سنه كان والناس
جميع يفطرون الساعه 12 بنفس التوقيت بما
يسمى بالتوقيت الغروبي او الساعه العربيه
وهي ساعه المتوائمه مع التكاليف الشرعيه
من راحه في الساعه الواحده فكانما قرب
بدنه فاليوم الشرعي يبدا من مغيب الشمس
فمساء الخميس نقول له ونسميه ليله الجمعه
وليله رمضان نبدا نصلي التراويح وليله
العيد نخرج زكاه الفطر ويبدا التكبير ومع
تواصل العالم في وسائل التواصل التقليديه
الراديو والتلفزيون انكمش هذا التوقيت
وتدخل علينا التوقيت الزوالي التي
نستخدمها الان فالساعه الغروبي تضبط
عقاربها مع غروب الشمس وساعه الزوالي تضبط
عقاربها مع زوال الشمس عقارب الساعه مع
الساعه هدور على منى ومالنا ما هي لنا
الادمي مخلوق يطغيها الغرور يبني امال
والموت
يهدم ما بنى
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والساعه الغروبي بين قوسين العربي واللي
اهلنا الاولين الله يرحمهم كانوا
يستخدمونه يتبع نظام الشمس الحقيقيه ليش
لان عقارب الساعه تضبط بشكل يومي على مغيب
الشمس والساعه الزوالي التي نستخدمها الان
تتبع نظام الشمس الخياليه والوقت انفس ما
عنيت بحفظه واراه اسهل ما عليك يضيع
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]